[Music]
and boob jobs for every way submitted by
Maina who and indian clinic is now
offering free boob jobs to women in
poverty I don't understand this because
I know India has not-so-good like rape
going on in it so girl rape is not so
good anybody if they have that whole
thing where women right now are just
being violated and that's [ __ ] up so
if I increase that number I bet some I
don't yeah what is a benefit in this
what the [ __ ] maybe it helps them get
jobs I hope now what kind of jobs I'll
open up what Vietnamese coffee shop out
there and call it an Indian coffee shop
mm-hmm
or chai shop mm-hmm chai Wan Chai yeah
yeah milk chai boobies a government
hospital in the southern Indian states
of Tamil and Madhu has launched a clinic
that will offer free breast
reconstruction surgery or reconstruction
as well as implementation oh yes
breast augmentation and they're saying
for men and women so what's
reconstruction me Mike so Mike after
breast cancer census yeah you get a
mastectomy and they reconstruct the
bride also tattoo nipples on that's cool
it looks really realistic I wonder if it
feels good still not the nerve endings
are gone so they're saying that it will
be free for patients on low income yeah
a lot of people are just criticizing
that's like why would you need to give
you know everyone OOP and so they're
saying that this is so to prevent other
people from going and getting cheaper
like black market like risking their
lives preventive now that it's
reconstructive I get it I'm like alright
cool cuz you know some women just want
to feel like women and and a lot of
women feel like they feel like women
when they got boob is so so this is so
bad that they're dating garage boobies
is it an epidemic or something like
garage
the hell-like backyard Indian boobies
huh like come to dr. Ajit I'll hook you
up you come to my backyard I'll [ __ ]
inject silicone in your boobs and in all
these women got like cheese silicone
it's [ __ ] like vegetable oil it's to
boil yeah and then they're gonna get
[ __ ] Swiss cheese boom you know it's
all [ __ ] messed up it's gonna look
like that [ __ ] lotus seed the sounds
all backwards though because do you
think that like if they're impoverished
right like they don't lower income like
cosmetics is the last thing they're
worrying about it's almost like are
people getting like backyard braces and
[ __ ] too like backyard eyebrow plucking
yeah it's not exactly like their life or
life is endangered by having no boobies
like yeah I know I didn't eat my last
four meals buying in abuja what eat
Myers get some food or [ __ ] people
are done like you've seen those chicks I
get like [ __ ] ass injections on their
face or their but whatever cuz you can't
afford the real ones
occult oh yeah oh yeah yeah I think this
is a money grab by the it's free
oh yeah it's free hmm for publicity oh
yeah what the government the government
pays them yeah it sounds like
interesting yes and then so the Health
Minister is also arguing that why should
beauty treatment not be available to the
poor I'm a middle-class Indian woman
then I have to pay for my boobs I'd be
like that's not fair
mm-hmm that's not fair I got to pay
twenty thousand dollars for my boobies
and they get it for free yeah I imagine
if like a in and like a really poor
chick it sells plastic surgery becomes
super hot maybe she comes like insta ho
and she makes hella money she finds that
a rich dude that's exactly what happens
those Russian [ __ ] happens every day
fine [ __ ] dude Lacaze
now you sound like you're in pain think
so I've seen photos of them before oh
but they're plastic surgery women yeah
and they significantly change their
faces and now they're like it's all like
Rolls Royce everything
yeah I follow some hookers as well as
rich millionaires and both you know it's
just interesting I'm like watching their
lives and I'm like damn dude this is so
bizarrely excessive mm-hmm that it's
interesting it's kind of like if if a
homeless guy had an Instagram I would
probably follow him too because it's
just so different from my life right but
usually when people are excessively
gaudy or rich or whatever it's because
they were dirt [ __ ] poor or like they
have to like you know new money they
gotta get the huge LV print they've got
to get the huge supreme mercy look at
this [ __ ] I'm wearing Gucci you know
like it's gotta it's gotta be huge like
you can't get the one that's like a
basic and then like the tag says Gucci
they've got to get the one that's good G
that's all the [ __ ] kids in the SUV
right now yeah well they did say though
there were about 420,000
procedures performed in 2016 compared to
three hundred and ninety thousand six
years earlier the more women arguing I
still don't understand cosmetics it's
like rich people I mean poor people that
are worrying about not having them right
nice clothes yeah apparently it's to
boost confidence too yeah I don't I
don't want more but I'm confident in
boys what if I want a bigger dick crazy
are the only servicing women because
that's sexist well they said men and
women but it's boobs so it's that guy
with nice boobies boy I wonder what
specks come in from like a Asian
perspective like hella Asian moms they
stopped even plucking their eye Roger
shaving their armpits just because
Chinese that you're talking about cuz
Korean mom's still a dope no no but
that's already outside of the power that
poverty line I'm talking about hustlers
like refugee immigrants that are coming
that are hustling there's a lot of like
frivolous things that they just drop
like I don't really give a [ __ ] let me
buy my mansion let me like hustle hard
and then take ten steps up and then I'll
get my makeover whatever but this seems
like you know what it's cool to just
stay down here get your makeover right
here I know you don't have food but
here's some titties it's such a really
weird perspective maybe the way to work
your way up in
I don't I don't know anything about
Indian society but maybe their society
is built a little differently than ours
and maybe do need to have a certain
aesthetic about you to claim I don't
know yeah that was the thing for this
particular clinic that apart from
providing breast surgery they will also
perform free cleft lip surgery okay for
children medical stuff like ding is dope
that's different and hand transplants
they're about the same [ __ ] I want
Jose hand give me his hands commit
crimes with only my left hand I knew you
wanted [ __ ] free your friend that bad
that's like some Nicolas Cage [ __ ] on
face off for something to take my
fingerprints was there wasn't a murderer
that like dried out someone's hands and
were like a glove and then committed
some sort of crime oh wow that's nice
something like house of a thousand
corpses yeah so you like the
fingerprints everywhere
yeah everywhere anyone fingerprints work
when your hands dried out like that
they still work leaves because there
isn't that oil that you leave behind for
fingerprints oh you just wear a rubber
glove you know like good point
you think both fat ass ladies and
[ __ ] Tijuana selling like blankets
and old guitars you think they care
about a [ __ ] implant no cuz they're
fat so they got big titties already what
about the flat-chested fat ones
wait a minute double o'clock this is
what you're missing is I'm really trying
to understand like poverty like
third-world I'm like what kind of
third-world [ __ ] will don't got
muffins to eat is [ __ ] trying to get
titties but this is a part you're
missing it's for [ __ ] free so now you
put a free thing but usually there is a
void right and then the government's
like let's answer this issue so the
issue exists first yeah so is there you
think in Tijuana you got those [ __ ]
dark ass [ __ ] fat ass ladies selling
blankets a titty layer
harm you in your past or something I'm
trying to understand poverty line but
you think in [ __ ] Cambodia there's
[ __ ] like told us women
that are trying to get titties first
before feeding the kids I mean I feel
like there's obviously a big chunk of
the article that wasn't information that
wasn't included in the article why would
the government back up something so
superficial if you will if there wasn't
like this because maybe government like
have a twister board and they just maybe
there's just a lot of women that's
getting the [ __ ] up titty jobs and
then getting infected or whatever and
yeah yeah there's so many its
reconstruction and reduction yeah but if
you think about it regardless if you're
poor or rich most people still want to
look good yes it's I think being a
refugee hard worker is a really rare
trait
that's why they they don't stay in
poverty for very long but if you think
about most people like let's say they
get a government check or whatever right
what do they do they kind of blow the
money on more [ __ ] or like how many
people do we know that they should be
[ __ ] saving up and live in you know
more responsibly but they go out and
[ __ ] buy rims or something I think
that's most people they want to look
good they want to feel good right now
vanity transcends all [ __ ] poverty
and rich and everything I think it's
because I'm when I'm thinking of poor
India I'm thinking of the people that
are taking a [ __ ] or showering in the
river
you're like sundog million yeah I'm like
a [ __ ] river shower is worried about
titties that's [ __ ] crazy
[Music]